asap rocky has been released from jail
the rapper real name rakim meyers was
arrested wednesday morning in connection
with a 2021 los angeles shooting rocky
was arrested at lax upon his return from
barbados where he was vacationing with
girlfriend rihanna who is pregnant with
their first child the 33 year old
musician was interviewed at the lapd
robbery homicide division before being
booked at the metropolitan detention
center rocky was released the same day
on a felony charge of assault with a
deadly weapon after posting 550 thousand
dollars bail
as for why he was arrested the lapd says
on november 6 2021 an argument between
two acquaintances occurred in the
hollywood area the authorities add the
argument escalated and resulted in the
suspect firing a handgun at the victim
the victim sustained a minor injury from
the incident and later sought medical
treatment following the shooting the
suspect and two additional males fled
the area on foot
shortly after rocky's arrest the lapd
executed a search warrant on his los
angeles home where a source tells et
that about six to seven lapd vehicles
were seen blocking traffic from entering
or exiting his residential street
no one other than police and a few
paparazzi were on the street during the
aftermath
so what's next a court date has been set
for august 17th the la district
attorney's office tells et that a case
has been presented and is under review
and since the news broke of his arrest
e.t has learned that rihanna is only
focused on one thing her pregnancy i'm
trying to enjoy it as much as i could
our source says this drama is the last
thing rihanna needs right now she wants
to be mellow relaxed and focused 100
percent on the arrival of her baby not
stressing out
rihanna made a point to navigate the
public side of her pregnancy on her own
terms and now suddenly things seem out
of her control e.t spoke with rocky in
february just one month after the couple
revealed they're starting a family
together what are you looking forward to
as you move into a new chapter of your
life i'm just excited for what i don't
know yet you know everything is new to
me so
you know i'm excited
[Music]